Americans often hear that we have the world's best healthcare system.
This is Dr. Brant James a
distinguished expert on healthcare quality at Intermountain Healthcare,
which is widely regarded as one of
the premier healthcare delivery systems in the United States.
Years ago he gave me the data for this graphic that shows that the
U.S. has the lowest mortality rates for high technology medicine,
the kind of care you need after a heart attack or major trauma.
That's the positive part of the story.
A Commonwealth Fund is
a private foundation that promotes a high performing healthcare system,
particularly for our most vulnerable citizens.
This graphic from its international research program shows that while the U.S. spends
around twice as much per capita on healthcare as six other industrialized nations.
Our overall rank is at the bottom on quality access efficiency and equity of care.
Our citizens also rank at the bottom with
respect to living long, healthy productive lives.